this week does mark one year since the  first coronavirus case here in the u.s  since then nearly 24 million people have  been infected  la now the first county los angeles in  the nation to hit  one million coveted cases and now it's  facing a new more contagious strain  former fda commissioner dr scott  gottlieb says this new variant of the  coronavirus is going to  increase infections this really changes  the equation and i think what we're  looking at  is a relentless strike from this virus  heading into the spring whereas  infections really would have started to  decline in the spring  vaccine roll out nationwide is still  slow  those who can get the vaccine have been  waiting for hours in many places  and supply is well short of demand so  far 12 million americans have gotten the  coronavirus vaccine